hello everyone I hope you're all having
a wonderful Sunday and we're back at the
1970 palma de merica inter-zonal
tournament it's around 20 and after
three consecutive wins Bobby Fischer
faces Canadian Grandmaster Duncan titles
he was not a grandmaster at the time
this game was played in 1970 but it's a
quite a funny story as Duncan Saddles is
perhaps the only person in the world who
kind of want his Grandmaster title twice
in 1968 in the Lugano Olympiad in
Switzerland he did achieve his final
Grandmaster norm but it was denied
because there was a technicality issue
he played that one game extra of in this
event then he should have to be able to
win his grandmaster more but it's quite
all right as he will win his Grandmaster
title in 1972 and it will be against the
former world champion Tigran Petrosian
so definitely a well-earned Grandmaster
title and not only is he a chess
grandmaster he's also a chess
grandmaster in correspondence chess so
you do not want to play a slow game
against this fellow before we check out
this game like we said round 20 we don't
have a nice photo challenge you know as
preparations for our Bobby Fischer
series so here it is best of luck to
everyone who is the gentleman in this
photo so there you have it you know it
should be an easy one but you know you
never know always good to keep expanding
that vast knowledge and now let's check
out this game there are already a couple
of moves on the board but it's quite
alright as they are the moves from the
game we have E for by subtles and here
Fischer goes for Knight to f6 once again
he employs the ideations defense he
refuses to show everyone what he really
will play against efore when the inter
zonal is over and when when he finally
faces the Soviets in the in the
candidates and after that in the World
Chess Championship so okay e5 Knight to
d5 d4 d6 + c4 nice to b6 this was played
in all of the games and here fish were
already faced in this tournament it
capture some visas but he also already
faced f4 so here as I'm pretty sure
Duncan knew that Fischer would go for
the aliens defense he he prepared a nice
price for Fisher he capture some d6c
capture some v6 and here we have Bishop
to e3 g6
and here comes d5 this is the surprise
no doubt a home preparation from Duncan
it grabs more space it doesn't tell our
Fisher to develop Knight to c6 but it
does give Fischer this beautiful
diagonal here so Fisher immediately uses
it Bishop to g7 and we have Bishop a d4
countering Fisher's Bishop here on this
diagonal Bishop captures Queen captures
and now you see that this advancing of
the d5 pawn doesn't allow Fischer to
play nice e6 to kick away the Queen and
the Queen is occupying a beautiful
central square here Fischer castles and
the now comes Knight to c3 you
definitely don't want to leave that
Queen and DeForest she is way too
powerful their salt Fischer goes 85 and
E 5 is an excellent move because white
would simply allow black too much if you
capture here then of course black will
first develop a knight with tempo the
Queen will be under attack after the
Queen moves and Bishop captures and the
black will be so far had in development
what the White King is still wide open
in the center and even if you run away
with a queenside castle there are so
many pieces already around your king
rook c8 is coming will be very
uncomfortable for white
so after a5 Queen d2 immediately not
grabbing the pawn and pass on f5 now
Fischer claims that White's calm
preparation isn't really all that much
and that this nice expansion all around
his King is quite all right and you know
the King does feel the draft there a bit
but you know Knight bt7 to f6 will
create a nice defense it's ok Knight f3
we have night 8 d7 queenside castle and
here white could have gone for plenty of
different things may perhaps not going
for castles immediately h4 and I was an
idea Knight g5 was an idea and perhaps
you know keeping his options open but he
decided to immediately go for this ok we
have Queen to f6 by Fischer Queen to h6
now and here Fischer in reply to Queenie
h6 brings this Queen back Queen to e7
because if you continue with something
like Knight c5 den Knight g5 will be a
nuisance queen e7 you have to defend
checkmate here and then h4 will be will
be troublesome for black but here Queen
to e7 stops this idea because now if you
try a knight the g5 would the same idea
Knight f6 and if you push h4 then 94
wins the game as the Queen has nowhere
to go now you don't lose the Queen but
you have to capture here and then after
captures captures captures white is down
a piece and black is completely winning
so after Queen to e7 rook to e1 was an
attempt we have E 4 by Fischer attacking
the knight on f3 Knight to d2 and now
Knight to e5 h3 you don't want to allow
Knight to g4 would an attack on the f2
pawn so h3 and now comes Knight be d7
Queen back to e3 as the attack is pretty
much over you do have to bring your
queen back to help out with the defense
Queen to h4 and now g3 kicking the Queen
back Queen to f3 and kink the b1 now
improving the safety of the King Knight
the c5 now both of these Knights are
eyeing that nice d3 square we have f4
and here Duncan would very much enjoy
Bobby to move this knife for example to
d3 and then after Bishop captures a pawn
captures or Knight captures attacking
the rook rogue defense okay this Knight
can't really move because there is this
annoying threat here but other than that
white should be able to hold it this so
Fischer agrees with him he does not move
the knight rather he captures on f3 on
Poisson we have Knight captures on f3
and now comes a beautiful move by
Fischer a very nice temporary pawn
sacrifice he pushes f4 you have to react
to this if you don't capture the pond
then Bishop f5 with check is coming into
play and then the d3 square will be
crucial so here we have pawn captures on
f4 and the now comes Knight captures on
f3
Queen captures and now comes Queen to h4
first the threatening the rook on e 1 as
the rook is undefended and the thing is
you you have to play something like
Bishop to e2 which was play
in the game you don't want to go back to
d3 you know in front of that Knight
Bishop to g2 is it doesn't work because
the c4 point is now undefended and after
rook captures on f4 you have to move the
Queen then Bishop comes into play first
Bishop f5 checking you want and then you
even lose the c4 pawn and then white is
busted here so after Queen to h4 Bishop
to e2 keeping an eye on the c4 pawn
bishop to f5 check first Fischer brings
the bishop into the game King to a1 and
now comes Luke 88 Fischer mobilizes all
of his pieces at the final rook is now
now comes into play rook c1 as the
bishop un'ytu was pinned we have Bishop
to b4 forcing now a trade if unless you
want to lose the exchange Knight
captures rook captures and now rook to
h2 we have rook captures on f4
Queen to c3 and now Queen to e7
pressuring this bishop here
Bishop to f1 is played and now comes a
rope to e3 Fischer increases the
pressure here Queen to d2 and now there
are two ways that improve increase the
pressure here you can even play this
rook to e4 or this rook to to f3
Fisher decides to go rook e to F 3 now
once again attacking the bishop here and
now if you move the bishop then you get
rook to f2 with a double attack on the
bishop after captures captures again
there's a double attack you can move the
bishop you're going to lose the Queen
after rook comes here Queenie 5 and
white is completely pinned down here
there's really nothing you can do black
will simply push a 5 a 4 a 3 bust open
the King and it's game over white can
never really push a 3 because night
check the King here wins the Queen so a
white would be lost here so after rook
eat to f3
rook to e2 attacks Fischer's Queen Queen
to f6 and the now comes the bishop to g2
you don't want to play something like
rook e8 checking f7 will simply attack
the rook and there will be a triple
attack against this bishop here as you
can see here Fischer's a giant gun is
very nicely employed here so brush up to
g2 attacking the rook rook to f2 as
planned
Roxy to e1 and here fresh or simply
exchanges rock cap
rook captures and now rook captors on c4
here Fischer did or basically the entire
thing he wanted to do first when he
played that f4 move he sacrificed upon
temporarily and now when all is said and
done it is actually Fischer who is up
upon and now you know there's really
nothing to do here for White Queen to e3
is played and Fischer immediately goes
for Queen to e5 offers the trade Queen's
white doesn't even have the luxury of
trading Queens because rook to see one
will be checkmate so first you have to
stop that King Tubby one is played and
now Fischer exchanges Queens as there
are a lot of other ways you can play
this position but Fischer is confident
in his ability to win this game being a
pawn up rook captures and now rook to F
for preparing rook F to Bishop to f3 not
allowing group to come to the second
rank and the now h5 King to see to
Duncan brings his King into the game
asking if seven Fischer does the same
King d2 and now here are very
interesting situation you want to play
rook h4 but before playing rock edge for
Fischer actually plays rook the b4 roof
to b4 is a move that engine prefers only
slightly above rook to h4 because it
forces the king to move back from the
center to protect the b2 pawn king to c3
is played and only now Luke to h4
attacking the h3 pawn you know slight
difference but you know everything
matters in the endgame Bishop to e2 if
you move the bishop or something so the
rook can defend the pawn then night we
for is coming with Czech Knight 2 f2 is
coming and then the pawn will be lost
so after Luke to h4 b for attacking
Fischer's knight Knight to d7 and now
Bishop to e2 now the rock is guarding
the dh3 pawn we have Knight to f6 and
now rook to a3 pinning the night so the
d5 pawn cannot be captured kink the g7
unpinning and now rugby 3 again
protecting the pawn we have g5 fisheries
preparing to push g4 and create a passed
pawn a 3 and now g4 if you capture H
capture sage captures the passed pawn is
created you can't go something like row
G 3 to block it because 94 check here
will win the rook so after g4 Bishop to
f1 is played we have 93 for this comes
with
King situ and now tonight to have to
attack in the rook and the h3 pawn rook
to e3 and now G captures on h3 creating
a beautiful passed pawn that defended
twice there's really nothing to do here
rook to e7 was played in the game
Fischer played king - king - f8
attacking the rook and it was in this
position that Duncan Saddles decided to
resign the game and move 52 why did he
resign
well his rock is under attack I have to
remove the rook of course you don't want
to push something like h2 immediately
here because then you could even survive
this after rook captures an f2 because
this comes with check King g7 then
Bishop to g2 and after you bring the
Queen into the game like it's still
better here but you are a pawn in a
Roxanne game so you would still have to
you know work for your meal so after
this rook to e2 first you don't want to
push h2 simply rook to a4 you defend the
night and now the eh pawn is also
guarded preparing to push it King d2 now
you push H - Bishop - G - defending and
now after agreeing the Queen into the
game Bishop captures Knight captures
white black will be up upon but also up
a whole night so yeah I have - king - a
faith Duncan didn't want to have any
more part in this game and he decided to
resign so a very nice game by Fischer
this is his third game in the palm of
America 1970 inter-zonal tournament
where he employed the aliens defense and
in this game also the aliens gun so very
nice and he did not lose a single game
using the aliens defense so very nice
for him as the Soviets will not know
what he plays for real when they play e4
against him
so now that's the game Duncan sorrows vs
Robert James Fisher of the 970
pamandmark enters on all tournament
round 20 I do hope you enjoyed it and
that you're enjoying the coverage of the
Bobby Fischer series we are very near
the end of the format America
inter-zonal so you know be prepared for
that I would like to thank you lea
insurance Sebastian Barton Nikolai
Dobrev and Danny McCullough for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check you all my
previous videos
here think all for watching and I will
see you soon with a couple more games
from the Bobby Fischer series and
perhaps if something you know unexpected
arises we're gonna cover that as well
and on a side note I did a friend of
mine who is really into Magic the
Gathering invited me of a foreign early
access to Magic the Gathering arena and
I have to say I am beyond impressed how
they you know made everything the
interface is wonderful and everything is
just highly enjoyable so you know if you
can do do check it out
so yeah I think oh and I'll see you soon